[Music]
in a cinematic universe that's 14 years
old so no wonder they've entered their
awkward phase comes takeaway td sequel
to ragnarok that feels a little how
should i put this
unfocused
nice
thor
love and thunder
ragnarok cranked up the comedy drama and
color up to 11. now see what happens
when you just keep cranking in a film
with the joke rate of family guy the
plot of fault in our stars and the look
of that time you shroomed at dave and
busters
[Music]
[Applause]
so we can download the distractions
that makes it clear marvel is pushing
their fx artist to the brink only to get
publicly roasted by their millionaire
bosses does that look real
in that particular shot no actually
you've watched thor find love find a new
weapon
and find himself now watch him find
excuses to run through the same
character arcs all over again as chris
hemsworth tries to squeeze something new
out of a role he's played for 10 years
and eight films but there's nothing left
for him to give except hang dong and be
done with it and flick
nice okay you can have a card now flick
too hard damn it
thrill at whatever different more
interesting movie christian bale is in
as he brings a menace to gore the god
butcher that comes from spending four
hours in makeup while your co-stars
walton has said in their pjs he's on a
quest to kill the gods themselves and
he'll kill exactly one of them on camera
in self-defense
placing him in the marvel hall of fame
of great actors wasted and disposable
villain roles and villains who are right
but marvel heroes only fight to preserve
the status quo
go child soldiers go save those elites
with your tiny little lives
rounding out a fantastic futhor of
heroes is valkyrie the king of new
asgard she's sort of an alcoholic that's
essential
sort of a viking warrior you pretty much
have to die in battle otherwise you
don't get into valhalla it's my plan
i wish i could join you but i'd probably
die and that won't help get the kids
back
and definitely the black best friend in
a rom-com about thor having sex with his
weapons it's sleek it's slender it's
powerful it's beautiful
for you i love it for you valkyrie
stormbreaker what are you doing is this
about mjolnir oh you moved on quick
didn't you
got some piece of work
what
we were just talking must be hard for
you to see your ex-girlfriend and your
ex hammer hanging out and getting on so
well
we good
yeah
i mean i know it's a little weird having
my ex weapon around but
come on me only in the past then there's
korg the urkel of asgard who's grown
from the comic relief to a main
character and the narrator who
steadfastly refuses to shut up shut up
or die turns out the only part of a
cronin that's alive is his mouth tell me
about it and jane foster thor's x who
stage four cancer is temporarily cured
by his hammer a subplot that would
require a careful balance of zany
fantasy and relatable pathos or you
could just make a joke out of it every
single time jane it's stage four i have
like how many stages four that we know
about ha ha
i thought maybe
if science isn't working maybe viking
space magic
something's affecting her body's ability
to fight the cancer i'm sorry thor
ah
there's a joke coming right some [ __ ]
made a fridge without a door can you
believe it
so lower your expectations for a candy
coated tumor held together by a hundred
screaming goat jokes
but hey not every comic book film has to
be so serious
or connect to the larger narrative of
the mcu
or bring a new dimension to favorite
characters
or introduce cool new heroes
or build up a new big villain
or have a central theme
or smoothly shift between tones
or explain what a god even is
or have clearly defined stakes
or make sense in general
or be consistently funny
or look good outside of action scenes
or
starring
bon god van damme
jane the version we wanted more of a
white christian who hates polytheism
test your might hey guys it's me cork
i'm the narrator now gonna be hearing a
whole lot more from me throughout the
whole entire movie actually basically
every scene hope you enjoy it it's
definitely what a thor me was supposed
to be all about very excited to be part
of it probably stop this at any moment i
wanted to but i'm convinced to get funny
enough but just keep on lingering about
and keep on talking the firstborn child
hemsworth promised to kevin feige
chad eater
hired guns the herc with the mouth thor
the dark world and every streamer at a
convention
good to see you in person buddy good to
see you
finding chemo
[Music]
wait is that us fun now he tried to
murder half the universe isn't this like
opening up a hitler burger
this comment is rated e for epic because
i read it in my epic voice
mission report december 16 1991
oh i got no respect no respect at all
i'm not saying it was aliens
but it was aliens